very much like to move on to what i
called the micro economic crisis which
is effectively
how the the financial system i
this is my summary of it is how the
financial system has worked or not
worked over the course of the last
decade our expectation is in a
capitalist economy that institutions
with failed business models should be
allowed to fail it's very clearly we for
reasons that are understandable if not
right for understandable reasons have
not let failed business models fail
and so the question is what is left of
our capitalism is there something right
at the heart of it a particularly well
remunerated section that is if you like
somehow not obeying the rules of
capitalism whereas everyone else is so
it's capitalism for the poor if you like
and uh socialism for the rich
so martin i very much like to get your
reflections on this and hear whether
you're still in this
the sort of city grand e
who
who defends it or whether you you
yourself see that something's gone awry
i hope this is not going to appear too
theoretical but
it would be much better
from the banking point of view
if banks could fail because then
you put your money
you this whole audience would put your
money with banks which were well managed
and those banks would pay less
interest on those deposits than banks
which were rationally managed
but that's absolutely a theory and is
not going to happen because
governments need votes and they need the
votes of people who've deposited their
money with failing banks like northern
rock
so the banks
are now effectively guaranteed by the
government when they're too big to fail
and that's a problem because that means
that you then have to rely on regulation
rather than market discipline to try and
manage banks properly and as soon as you
rely on regulation
then everybody running a bank
will
behave up to the limits of regulation
rather than commercial
prudence banking commercial prudence
and you know your competitors are going
to do that so you're tempted to do it
like that yourselves and the
big problem and i'm just going to stop
in one moment the big problem that we
had in
the
run-up to 207 was that the regulators
did an incredibly bad job
they allowed banks
to treat us aaa assets
stuff which was nowhere near aaa assets
so that when you blame banks as i expect
many of you do
pay attention to the other people who
you should blame which are the
regulators the rating agencies the
accountants
and
of course primarily governments who
allowed this to happen but you but
you're not advocating in capitalism
the whole system has to hinge on having
better regulators than yes howard davis
and the dare turner and
mervin king and
i mean you know these were the people
who were i hope you're not going to ask
me to comment on any of those names no
but but but you're but you're but you're
saying the system actually that the
whole thing hinges on finding a better
set of regulators next time that seems
like a very tall order no i think well i
think it certainly does depend on having
good regulators there's no question
about that but i think there are also
market disciplines which you can try and
uh reintroduce which would improve the
situation it it is significant that the
banks which were owned by the which were
managed by the people who owned them
of which there are a few left did not
get into trouble
diane i know you've won
sorry diane
um
regulation is certainly not the answer i
think there's a clue about too big to
fail in the too big part of that
and we'd had two generations of banks
merging
with each other and becoming bigger and
bigger
no successful new entrance into into
banking in in um for current accounts
and mortgages and so forth
there's a more modern more advanced
banking system in kenya now than those
in the uk because the mobile phone
companies have entered with financial
transactions by mobile and in this
country you can't get into the market
for current accounts mortgages you can't
get into the into the into the payment
system
there's an absence of competition and
the banking monopoly the banking bonuses
come from the fact there are monopoly
profits in banking there's no pressure
on banks to serve their customers
properly to give them better rates to
innovate in ways that help customers
rather than
their own ability to make profits and
pay themselves bonuses so i think it's
not regulation but an absolute absence
of competition in the development of
these powerful oligopolies that
influence the political process
linda you
you work on bloomberg television which
covers the financial sector
more than i mean one of two essentially
24 hours round the clock covers the
financial sector do you ever
think
god this is all so
appalling this is this whole thing is
not working do you ever have that here i
am i'm
giving a sort of minute by minute market
commentary economic every piece of data
poured over
which is just a sort of
a random noise over which some of our
best brains are trying to see patterns
um
do you never as one of those best brains
stand back and think isn't there
something i can do
i feel really motivated to go in
tomorrow
um
yeah i i i mean i i agree with what um
you know diane has just said i often i
find it
just
quite astounding sometimes um the degree
to which we're still trying to sort out
the mess from a few years ago and when
you look at the bonus culture which is
still there really not much seems to
have changed um i mean as an economist
i'm a strong believer in incentives and
i think there's certainly a deeper uh
look not the minute by minute movement
of
the market but a deeper look at how it
is that we have structured the banking
system and the role that it plays in the
society
and the incentives are obviously set up
by government by regulators but also
it's the responsibility of the bankers
themselves so i've always been a a huge
uh i'm a lawyer as well by training i
used to be a corporate lawyer and
lawyers have this great phrase where we
don't believe that regulators can set up
anything properly in the first place and
all those come about through what's
called the crash then law hypothesis
so you have to have some type of
collapse in the market or some type of
issue and then you have the stakeholders
to re-examine what has happened and then
you try and formulate the next step you
shut the stable door yeah yeah exactly
and then the criticism is that it was
formulated for the last crisis but it
does keep the lawyers employed for the
meanwhile
but i suppose i think my my bigger point
is that i think this crisis has i think
raised questions about what is the role
of banks in a in a society and i think
we're having the right kinds of
discussions about it and i don't think
we're going to come up with a perfect
solution because the lawyer and me
always thinks there's work to be done
for lawyers i take anatole and then
thomas
um well i i finally we've got some real
disagreement because i disagree with
everything that everybody has said has
said on this panel because i think what
we're missing this nice wrong view is
that we're missing the essence of this
which is that actually it is the market
that has failed and it is it's not a
particular market that's failed it's the
whole philosophy of relying on the
market that has failed this is not about
regulators not being clever enough you
know how how davis and mervin king at
least as clever certainly harder working
than governors of the bank of england
used to be you know people like robin
lee pemberton who used to leave on
friday afternoon to go shooting uh it's
not that they're not clever enough but
it's that they felt until a few years
ago that it was the job of regulators to
follow the market to look at market
signals and to believe that the market
knows best now of course if you have a
regulator who says the market knows best
and you can't back the market he's not
doing the job similarly it's not about
competition there's plenty of
competition investment banking which is
where all the real money is made the
fact that there's no competition between
clearing banks has nothing to do with
the high pay of bankers nor is it about
private ownership lehman was a privately
owned bank dickfold owned 30 of the
shares of lehman he lost 2 billion
overnight it didn't affect his
management of it and nor is it about too
big to fail northern rock was not too
big to fail every bank is too big to
fail modern society because none of you
are willing to put a thousand pounds in
the bank and lose any of it quite
rightly in a modern society we assume
that banks are safe so all these
market solutions are not going to work
there's got to be a recognition that
there are certain parts of economic
activity where the market should not
rule they should be ruled by political
and administrative decision making
right thomas
that's exactly right here here
so
you know um i came over here from
america which over the last what 15
years has just become this sort of
panorama of epic corporate fraud
right you go back and look at from the
end from the enron debacle
up to the to the housing bubble it's
just you know one damn thing after
another
um and you think of all the different
you know we were talking about uh
banking prudence and market discipline
just think about the the i mean the
incredible ways that that discipline has
fallen apart
think about you know all the conflicts
of interest at enron you guys remember
enron you know about this right were
these people they the accountants were
basically signing off on these
just
staggering conflicts of interest why
because the incentives
told them to do it because that's that's
the way the incentives wanted that you
wanted everything to go that's the way
the market wanted it you look at the um
the sort of the scandals of the
corporate boards who are approving these
lavish paydays these unbelievable
paydays for ceos that are driving
companies into the ground you know or
for you know all the bonuses for these
traders you know that selling the
poisoned the poison bonds back and forth
to one another you look at the remember
the scandal with the wall street stock
pickers not the stock pickers what's
that remember that there was a guy in
new york who deliberately changed his
rating on a stock in order to get his
kid into a into a fancy
uh preschool
you remember this
uh there's a big scandal in 2001 2002
when all of the and then you of course
you have the very similar scandal of the
bond rating agencies you you were
referring to this a second ago rating
this these sort of you know
mortgage-backed securities which
everyone knew were [ __ ] right and rating
them aaa gold-plated right this wasn't
the government that did this this this
was this is the private bond rating
agencies in america or you think of the
jesus christ the professional economists
that just sat on their hands and watched
all this
now the this is this is the failure of
you know market incentives okay but you
look at the failure of the regulators
which is equally pronounced this is an
amazing story and this is something i
know a great deal about because my last
book was about regulatory failure the
wrecking crew it was called it came out
be in in in 2008 but
i'll just give you
one anecdote from from the days of the
bush administration when um there are
five different regulators for banks in
america five different agencies and they
were just systematically subverted okay
defunded i mean you look at the
securities and exchange commission where
basically these guys okay these lawyers
in washington paid on government
salaries they're going up against the
most you know fantastically paid lawyers
in the world wall street lawyers these
guys in the securities exchange
commission have to make their own
photocopies
right because they they don't they don't
have secretaries because they work for
the government and of course their
photocopiers are broken right so they're
they're down there waiting in line at
kinko's to make their photocopiers but
the story that's the best
there's one of the one of the five
regulators is called the office of
thrift supervision and these people do
you know about these people they just
happened to be the regulator that was
supposed to be overseeing um i'm going
to get it wrong but some of the biggest
bank failures in u.s history washington
mutual indie mac okay
these guys were um
sort of that what they what they would
do in america over the la the course of
the last 30 years is you fill these
regulatory agencies with lobbyists from
the the industry that's regulated and
this was done deliberately
and there's all sorts of theories for
why you should do it this way and market
discipline and listen to the markets and
blah blah blah market-based government
but the guy that they had at uh at this
particular regulatory agency just it
sort of symbolizes the whole
bush era approach to uh regulation he
had this uh photo this photo opportunity
where he was posing with a bunch of of
lobbyists from the banking industry
these are the guys he's the the industry
he's supposed to be overseeing remember
and the the the
the the title for the photo the big
backdrop that they're standing in front
of says cutting red tape and they've all
brought garden implements to cut to show
how committed they are to cutting red
tape this is the regulator right meeting
with the lobbyist and the regulator has
brought a chainsaw
right
that's what happened and it happened
that way because we put people like that
not we because the the people running
the american government put people like
that in office deliberately okay they
sabotaged the system on purpose
okay i'm shutting up now sorry about
that very very interesting very
interesting um
i just want to i wanted to slightly i
will
let john come in but i want to just
slightly redirect
redirect this because there's a sort of
specifics of banking and regulation
but
someone in the city said to me something
uh he he said basically the best brains
in the city
apply their minds to arbitraging the
value out of institutions structures
deals corporations and transferring it
to themselves
rather than
creating value in those institutions and
we have seen i mean take a very good
example private equity which essentially
went into companies a lot of companies
took them over
very brainy people loaded them with debt
sold them at the height of a boom
and then the companies were left more or
less wrecked and the question was
those people
we wasted an awful lot of very clever
people in an activity which is
essentially grabbing rather than
creating uh warren buffett puts it very
well he said well if we did all land on
a
desert island we wouldn't really have
the 10 cleverest people among the 100 of
us
trading futures in the crop that the
other 90 were trying to grow we would
actually ask the 10 to be thinking about
how the hell to grow more
and
john i just wonder
just getting beyond the banks the whole
role of financial capitalism yeah i mean
i think that's the key issue evan and
let's come back to it if we may after
understanding what is going on in the
banks
actually we know the answer to the
banking problem
in britain we did not have a banking
failure of any significance in the
course of the 20th century
why didn't we have a banking failure in
the course of the 20th century it's
because we had a relatively small number
of conservatively run boring banks
what they did was they took in deposits
and they lent some of what they took in
out mainly to people who didn't very
much need it
and we had building societies which
collected people's savings and they lent
them out to house buyers who would be uh
willing to pay but pay the money back
otherwise they'd be put out of their
houses
and that system worked perfectly well
and the reason it stopped working at the
end of the century was we allowed these
institutions to turn themselves into
financial conglomerates which used the
security of the deposits and savings of
everyone in this room as collateral for
speculative trading let me tell you what
british banks do
the total balance sheets of british
banks are between six and seven trillion
pounds the amounts of money that are so
large you can't imagine it
about a quarter of that consists of
residential mortgages of the boring
loans you and i take out to buy our
houses
and that's by far the biggest thing that
banks do for the real economy
banking is basically the boring business
of helping taking in our savings and
helping us buy our houses
there's a tiny amount which is the
amount which is really important and we
should all be really concerned about
which is lending to non-financial
businesses
but that's a tiny part of what we're
talking about here it's about 200 mil
billion of that six to seven trillion
it's about three percent of the total
what's all the rest
the rest consists almost entirely of
financial institutions trading with each
other
now common sense suggests that people
passing around the same bits of paper
back and forwards to each other
they're not
in aggregate adding any value to that
process
and you might ask what is wrong with
that common sense
and i've been studying this for a long
time and no one has ever really managed
to give me the answer
so what do we do
you began evan by saying well the way
capitalism works is when businesses fail
we shut them down
and that's right
now when these businesses failed in 2008
we couldn't shut them down
because we'd have been shutting down as
you explained
not just this merry-go-round of people
lending money back and forwards to each
other but we'd have been shutting down
the institutions that look after our
payments and our savings and so on but
what we should be doing is an orderly
winding down
and of this particular process
we ought to go back to boring banks
that take money in and lend some of it
out
bill
mortgage banks that collect our savings
and lend it out to people on unsound
mortgages now i don't want to stop
people
lending money back and forwards to each
other if it if it amuses them i don't
think that i don't think it's going to
be a very profitable business in the
long run in fact i'm pretty sure it's
not going to be a very profitable
business in the
in the long run if they can't divert the
profits from boring banking activities
into their own profits but they should
use their own money for it and in due
course it will wind itself down and
that's actually the market operating in
the way it should do and that's what we
should be trying to achieve
we'll open up to the floor i'm just
going to ask stephen to make a comment
because he works for a bank he's not a
banker in any normal sense of the word
he's an economist he could be working
for a ratings agency for example
um
no or or an or a university department
um
you can make you sound very
your bank is actually the the one that
is probably the least
the least question marks over to the uh
virtually any in the world over the last
decade well you're very kind i can't
speak for the bank itself but uh i i
will make a couple of observations the
first is that i am just an economist at
hsbc um and that proves that my brain
can't be very big because you've been
talking about these people doing trading
and futures and so on they have a very
big brain so i don't really understand
what they're doing
but secondly i just wanted to uh make a
comment okay that's the problem yeah
that's possibly the case
but i think
one thing i'd like to add on this going
back to john's comments about um these
uh nice cozy banks in the past as a
back in the 50s and 60s there was very
little competition in banking it was a
nice cozy arrangement
but for many people who perhaps wanted
to buy a house they couldn't do so very
easily because they had to get in the
queue for mortgages and by queuing they
had to wait for a number of months
before their mortgage was approved
we moved completely in the opposite
direction over the course of the last
few years where virtually anyone can get
hold of a mortgage partly because of the
massive increase in competition
the competition wasn't just
associated with what was going on
within individual countries it was a
move towards a much more globally
competitive capital market i mean one of
the biggest
revolutions over the last um two or
three decades has been this
extraordinary increase in cross-border
capital flow which makes it so much more
difficult to regulate uh capital markets
that might have been the case in the
past
and so the difficulties that came
through over the course of the last few
years particularly in the uk uh were not
just associated with the uk banks
themselves but also the arrival in the
uk
of icelandic banks irish banks a whole
range of other banks which increased
competition
reduced the profitability of each
individual bank and frankly encourage
banks to take far too much risk because
they have to take the risk to try and
reward their shareholders who are
frustrated with the low rates of return
now we could go back to a world
of capital controls of restrictions on
cross-border activity
we could go back to the 50s and 60s and
many people say that's great because
that was a period of strong growth
with relatively low unemployment
relatively low inflation all those
things were wonderful
but at the same time we should also
remember that the opening up of capital
flows around the world has been
extraordinarily important not so much in
the states
or in europe
but in opening up opportunities for
countries which have been stuck in
poverty
for hundreds and hundreds of years i'm
thinking here of china india parts of
latin america all of whom have frankly
been the biggest beneficiaries
of the opening up of global capital
markets over the course of the last few
years so i think sometimes there's a
kind of parochial focus of what's going
on in the uk or the us which is entirely
understandable
but sometimes we need to realize what
the choices are if we move away from
this free flow of capital across borders
towards something which is much more uh
regulated sorry stephen we're not
lending to china china is lending to us
it's very hard to believe but the global
capital flows
the global imbalances that people talk
about consist of the savings of chinese
peasants financing the excess
consumption
of people in britain and the united
states
well that's probably the most bizarre
development imaginable that's not quite
true i i think the way it works is
effectively the chinese effectively
deposit money into the us or the uk us
and uk companies who have the money then
reinvest back into china
and so effectively a lot of the chinese
growth has come as a consequence of
western companies investing in china
i think that's something which has been
pretty important in recent years
i want to open this up to the floor i
want to get some of your comments um
we've got a gentleman here and we've got
uh if we've got one upstairs yes we'll
take one upstairs and we'll take one
over there but we'll start if this
gentleman has the mic yes go ahead
taking up the theme of john kay about
the
the the dangers of the banking system
passing uh pieces of paper to each other
and the
proportion of their activities that that
represents many people would say that
that was enabled but by the repeal of
the glass-steagall act which happened i
think during the the clinton
administration um the glass-steagall
which had been put in place i think
after the um
the terrible um depression of the
1929-1930 time
to protect against the sort of uh
dangers which um culminated in 2008 so
my question would be um is it really
possible for that winding down which
john k was hoping would take place
unless there is something
really like glass-steagall put back in
place and which has more teeth than it
seems the vicar's recommendations um uh
would lead us to expect thank you for
that um who on the panel wants to
contribute to that okay thomas give us a
very very strong american very quick
this is an um the glass-steagall act is
in the united states this uh i bet you
knew that
we did it most of us have now heard of
glass-steagall we've separated the banks
yeah it separated investment banking and
commercial banking and uh there there
was a um
and and yeah it does have some it has
some role in i mean it allowed too big
to fail basically although the term too
big to fail came about you know was
invented before they repealed
glass-steagall and this is i mean it's a
very long story and i'm not going to
bore you with the whole thing but um
there was a uh there were a lot of
people talking about bringing back some
version of it most notably paul volcker
who is a former
chairman of the federal reserve board in
the united states
and uh
you know
there's not a whole lot of political
will to do something like that and this
is this is the really depressing it's
doing something here though i mean john
is it is it remotely
addressing the issue that you it is
thomas is of course right that
glass-steagall was an american
a piece of american legislation but in
the united kingdom we had an effective
glass-steagall provision until really
two two groups of changes one came in
the early 1970s from a policy known as
competition and credit control and the
other more important was the group of
issues around about big bang in the mid
1980s and what was happening in the same
period in the united states is
glass-steagall was being steadily eroded
until it was finally repealed in 1999
and it was essentially the
transformation of a financial services
industry in which
commercial banks did the kind of things
that traditional commercial banks did
building societies did what building
societies did insurance companies did
what insurance companies did market
makers and stock brokers did what they
did and so on there were silos of
different businesses in different areas
and all these demarcations
were swept away
and we got the emergence of these
wide-ranging uncontrollable poorly
managed financial conglomerates in
retrospect it was a mistake and those in
the audience who say we should reverse
that mistake are absolutely right and
getting to the essence of the matter um
gideon did you want to come in there no
no we're going to talk about your
element yep come on
hello thanks i just want to
make a quick point and then ask a quick
question of the panel uh the point is
whether it's john k whether it's anatoly
koletsky um whether it's our american or
friend i can't remember your name i'm
sorry um and my eyesight is too poor to
read the thing in front of you
um
what we're looking at fundamentally it
seems to me is a failure of culture that
is my point
and my question is which we're beginning
to touch on in the second part of that
micro
economic
discussion which to do with
protectionism
and it my limited understanding of
economic history is that previous
periods of globalization have been
um followed by periods of protectionism
and i'm wondering if we are entering a
new phase of prediction but i actually
really like the the point you made the
first part because i think if you
look at a whole lot of industries you
could look at the newspaper industry now
and you could listen to
levison inquiry
interviewing newspaper editors and you
just think actually
there was no regulatory system you could
have imposed that would stop this or
actually we had a regulatory system that
was designed to stop this but there was
a culture of everybody just pushing
a little bit too aggressively up to a
kind of line that they thought they they
had i do want to just ask them i mean
anatol do you think
there's any hope that says any hope for
saying
actually we can improve our capitalism
by just making people somewhat better
and
more restrained a little bit more moral
a little bit less kind of quick buck
earn here buccaneering
well better no but uh less oriented
towards earning a quick buck absolutely
yes but i don't think this is a question
i think you're absolutely right about
culture it's not about virtue uh and and
the point about the culture is that we
went through this basically well you
know what my book was was about that you
know
from 1980 onwards we went through 20
years in which we were told that there
is this
supernatural force above all our lives
above all our judgments above all our
moral
instincts which is the market and if the
market does something it must be right
if the market decides that some a banker
deserves to be paid 500 million dollars
a year or a hedge fund manager which
they do earn this is some of them do
earn that then that is appropriate it's
fair and just uh and you know even in
our industry uh james murdoch you're a
very famous gave this very famous speech
about four years ago at the at the
edinburgh festival in which he said the
only guarantee of
sound journalistic ethics is the market
is the profit motive i mean that was
basically what his speech was about so
if you believe that everything
ultimately has to be proved ruled by the
market the profit motive you can't have
regulation you can't have
self-regulation or responsibility either
well i mean
i think we should remember that there
was a reason why there was such a surge
of confidence in the market is that
we've just seen the catastrophic failure
of an entire system built on bucking the
market would be you know the soviet
union and the soviet empire
we should go too far in the other
direction yeah uh anyone else want to
give a quick mr martin i i'd just like
to
just going back to something john said
in the last century we did have bank
failures i think he's forgotten about
the secondary banking crisis in the
1970s and what happened in those days
was
and indeed before was that when a bank
became too weak
and looked like being unable to repay
its deposits it was taken over by
another stronger bank which is why we
ended up with so few banks and of course
diana is absolutely right the
competition
more competition uh would be a very very
good thing but all these the rather glib
at least to me is rather glib
case for reverting to the glass-steagall
act is based on a misapprehension of
what was going on in the united states
at the time it was introduced and what
could happen now and with modern
technology and modern means of
communication it would be completely
impossible and unnecessary to go back to
the last legal act but
uh the vicar's commission which is a
very sensible
report they came out with i disagree
with parts of it of course
as i would but basically it's going in
the right direction to try and make
uh banking regulated imperfectly as it
is a little bit safer
right we've got time for one more
question over there back there yep
it's gone okay um
have we got another question on this
whole issue we've got a gentleman over
there let's uh let's let them have the
last word on this
and then we'll move on to the eurozone
which is the easy one yeah hi why were
there no conditions attached to the
loans that the bailed out banks received
because it seems to me that everyone
complains that rbs share price has gone
down and rbs isn't profitable and yet
they're still paying out bonuses and
they're still lavish corporate
entertainment
my question is
it seems like you're trying to close the
stable door after the horses bolted
shouldn't have conditions been attached
when the loans were actually given to
these banks rather than trying to i mean
afterwards we attached one very
important condition which was that we
owned 83 of it
in return for the investment that we
made which obviously would allow us to
would allow us to do whatever we want
more or less if we chose to exercise it
so the
interestingly the question is why we do
not choose
to run rbs
in a completely different way i think is
a i'm slightly rephrasing your question
but we do own it and we can do what we
want with it it's our bank um
linda would you run it very differently
would you keep it at this sort of arm's
length
and
there i can understand why um the
government wants to run at arm's length
because they're worried about going too
far kind of gideon's point from a moment
ago that we seem to reject the way the
market works so we all seem to mind some
countries like china yeah yeah that
somehow if you have a state-run banking
system it would be um better but i think
that being said i think given where the
economy currently is there's a very
strong argument for using banks which
are essentially state-owned to inject
more credit into the economy and not to
worry so much about running it on a
commercial basis through this period
it does seem remarkable we want banks to
do something and we only own eighty two
percent of a very big one which has
branches all over the country and we
don't
go out and make it happen yeah exactly
so i have quite a lot i do think that is
you know a good point to be made can i
just finish very quickly on a point on
china just because i think we kind of
feel like we're we're all going to move
into a chinese state-led model
the um
i've looked at china for a number of
years and actually one of the
extraordinary things about those who
study china is that they often think
that china works because the market
developed in spite of the government
and but the advantage i think of china
is that it has managed to build up
institutions while injecting incentives
for the market and did it very very
slowly so when something goes wrong they
can pull back and not do it and i think
in that way it's allowed it to
transition for 30 years at a very good
pace but i would just hasten to warn we
ought not draw too many lessons because
china's such an unusual country and i
know that we tend to uh we tend to
admire its current growth rate but just
on very quickly in the banks one of the
biggest worries about uh for the chinese
is the state of their banks um so we
don't know how the story ends exactly
let's not judge
last word on this to diane
it's easier to let things run at arm's
length if you set out the system the
right way in the first place and the
banks have got bonus schemes that reward
people for how
they manipulate the share price over
time which encourages them to take risks
which seems a very bad thing to
encourage bankers to do
and if we had a system where bonuses
depended on the things that we'd like
them to do like
lend money to businesses profitably over
time
get high customer satisfaction schools
and not miss sell products to their
customers and that would be a better
scheme and they could run it themselves
right
um we're going to move on to the euro
before we do let's just take a vote how
many people here that the voters is
don't put your hands up yet
how many people here think
the attack on bankers is overdone that's
going to be yes and how many of you
people how many people think the attack
on bankers is not overdone no so
anti-banker no
pro-banker yes
okay how many of you think the attack on
bankers is overdone
and how many of you think it is not
overdone
what do you reckon 60 40 against the
banks yeah about 60 40 against that
thank you
you